make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin okay what's going on guys
this
is rob and we are picking back up again
with dcs with dead planet
number two and this one actually gives
us a group called shadow pack but we'll
talk about that here in a little bit
what it really does
is it opens up with arsenal red arrow
whatever you want to call them uh but it
opens up with roy harper and the cool
thing about this is
it kind of gives us a little bit of an
indication of the fact that things are
still kind of continuing on right
because one of the things to understand
for those of you guys who didn't see the
first video
and you'll find the full dc's playlist
down in the description but for those of
you guys who didn't see the first video
that what you had here
was basically just five years that have
passed since the initial
outbreak of the virus right that's where
dead planet picks up the main deceased
event happens the virus breaks out it's
everybody kind of panicking basically
the superheroes vacating earth and then
five years later
dead planet takes place and so for the
last five years roy harper's basically
been on earth trying to hold off these
monsters essentially you know these
more or less undead people now one of
the cool things to also realize here is
that roy harper is one of many heroes
who did that
right the whole situation escalated so
astronomically fast right we're talking
about within the span of a day the whole
situation escalated so fast that there
wasn't really enough time to get
everybody off earth right it was
basically the superheroes like superman
and martian manhunter and barry allen
and those guys doing what they could
where they could but as we saw they all
basically fell you know over the span of
a day or two they were trying to get as
many
normal humans off planet as they
possibly could and the expectation is
that they would come back and they would
grab everybody else as soon as they
could but the result is that that didn't
happen right so roy harper's just been
kind of making it and when you're
thinking about it that way it's actually
kind of sad right that roy harper is one
of a multitude of heroes who were just
sort of left behind
in the initial outbreak of all of this
now the other part of that is of course
you have all these various you know kids
and
and so on these adults and and people
who are being protected by roy harper
but the issue is that as soon as we kind
of get this glimpse of the fact that
he's here he's immediately incinerated
right he's completely and totally
destroyed and that leads to the rival
to the arrival of john constantine and
shadow pack now shadow patch is a group
that's actually been around for a long
time in dc comics right they're not new
to the dc's landscape
shadow pack first appeared in uh in dc
comics and days of vengeance number one
back in 2005 right so they've been
around for about 15 years or so now the
original roster as far as i'm aware of
consisted of enchantress ragman
detective champ blue devil nightshade
and nightmaster and then i think it also
had constantine but the idea behind that
was
basically like a supernatural team dc
for the most part had their whole
supernatural element and it didn't
really cross over a lot with the main
superheroes that's what made jon
constantine so intriguing is because for
a lot of fans
john constantine cross over with people
like that all the time right with
superman wonder woman batman those
various characters enchantress did is
you know to a degree but detective champ
blue devil he never really saw those
kind of characters cross over with dc
a whole lot i will say with blue devil
it was a little bit different because he
originally appeared in the firestorm
comics so to a degree he did but
it's it's one of these cool situations
because it's basically like a
supernatural superhero team
but for the most part shadowpatch gets
in there and immediately goes to work
now one of the things that i want you
guys to notice here
is that unlike the the main deceased
event where they came across all these
various humans and the idea was to save
the individuals they could that's
changed right we saw that change during
hope at world's end and we even saw a
change towards the latter end of the
deceased event right that the various
superheroes were kind of looking at that
and saying okay there's nothing we can
do to save these guys right
they're gone now right they're basically
broken now we as the reader knew
they could be saved we knew that by
virtue of cyborg and the fact that there
was actually a cure right we've known
that for a little while but for the most
part when you have shadow pack facing
off against you know these normal humans
it's what you would expect right i mean
these are normal regular
average joes right soccer moms hockey
dads not a whole lot going on there but
then suddenly
swamp thing appears now swamp thing is
kind of like the unsung hero
of deceased if i'm being honest with you
guys because what dc did here and i feel
like this is really just sort of a of a
of a hurrah
for swamp thing fans is this guy is is a
total
force to be reckoned with like and he
always seems to show up at the most
inopportune times
right like they're in the middle of a
great big huge fight and then he pops up
and tells constantine he needs to talk
about a garden it's like okay look man
that's cool and everything
don't care about your radishes we got a
great big huge conflict going on here we
need to cope with this right we need to
deal with this i'm sure the radishes
will be fine
right like but that's that's not really
what's what's happening here but when
constantine says like we have this great
big huge thing i don't really have time
for this
swamp thing summons the green and then
takes all the humans out like that
that's what makes swamp thing so cool is
because aside from like
super powered individuals that have the
ability to overcome his powers no one
else is really going to stand against
him right so at any given time and
seemingly if he chose to swamp thing
could probably eradicate every single
infected human on earth within a day or
two but of course once all these these
humans here are dealt with then swamp
thing starts talking to constantine and
what he says
is that yes there's a god there's a
garden in gotham city that was created
by poison ivy as a safe haven but
there's also one in australia and that
the garden itself is screaming out now
constantine almost kind of like
begins to blow off you know uh blow off
swamp thing and swamp thing just freaks
out and presses at him
which is something that you never see
and everybody's just kind of like damn
man
did swamp thing really just just do that
and constantine's like yeah man
he did you know i kind of got him to
that point so i'm a little bit proud of
it you know i'm kind of glad that i got
him to that place uh which
is kind of cool to be honest but
basically uh swamp thing kind of reveals
that this this garden needs to be looked
at like whatever is that's going on here
swamp thing cannot get inside he cannot
access it himself and so they need to
respond they need to find out what's
happening here
right so jump forward to the garden in
gotham city which is grown
by a huge margin since it was originally
created now again this is poison that
poison ivy is doing right where swamp
thing has the ability to tap into the
green which is to say nature itself
right trees bushes all that kind of
stuff poison ivy can basically do the
same thing for the longest time that was
never the case for the longest time
she was just a chick that loved plants
it wasn't until more recently in dc
comics relatively speaking to the time
the publisher's been around that poison
ivy was kind of tied into the green that
she was basically an elemental and she
was able to manipulate the green
in the same way swamp thing does but one
of the things that's kind of given to us
here sort of solidified is that it's not
enough to have this this garden is kind
of ever
you know constantly shifting constantly
changing so that none of the undead can
access it just to make sure there are no
weak points right that's one of the
small
one of the smart things here is that if
this garden was static which is to say
it didn't
change it was just this giant erected
wall of like greenery and
and whatnot then as the undead kept
flinging themselves against it it would
create weak structural points and that
would inevitably lead to
one of these points breaking and then
the undead flooding in but the fact that
it's changing and shifting all the time
means there are no weak points but it
wasn't enough for the for the various
walls themselves because there were also
various superhuman beings out there
right who could penetrate these walls
destroy them and so the green walls
themselves were actually fortified
through the magic of dr fate right the
tower of fate which basically provides a
kind of level of magical protection
against whatever forces may be out there
now it's not all encompassing but it's
not an indestructible force field right
we know that there are weaknesses there
and a being of sufficient power
can overtake it but what you end up
having here is of course kind of this
this detection system that more or less
comes with this wall
that lets poison ivy and the various
individuals know that somebody's coming
and of course this leads to mary marvel
you know using the power of shazam to
become you know
very marvelous am person right there her
name's actually mary marvel she doesn't
get a name like shazam
with dr fate dawning his helmet and then
of course mary marvel kind of going out
there they immediately meet cassie
sandsmark right now cassie sandsmark is
a character who has been wonder woman on
a multitude of instances over the course
of dc comics and in reality once she
popped up and once she developed her fan
base which is
a hardcore fan base here's the thing
guys there are some characters in comics
where fans won't hear a word against
them and cassie sandsmark fans
love cassie sandsmark if you walk up to
one of the cassie sandsmark fans and
you're like hey
so this character is basically just a
poor man's wonder woman they'll get
pissed
they'll get they'll they'll freak right
they'll actually lose their minds no
that's not true at all she's better
wonder woman than diana prince was you
know
pulling out all these arguments and all
that kind of stuff it's honestly i've
watched it happen
it's kind of funny right like funny
story we were at new york comic con one
year and myself and benny and sal and
all of us were hanging out and
we were hanging out with fans we were
talking to fans different things like
that and one of the fans kind of made
this offhanded comment of how like
cassie sandsmark was not that
interesting of a wonder woman these two
fans ended up like not really
arguing and like fighting but like
debating with each other for something
like 35 minutes going back and forth
over whether or not cassie sandsmart was
actually a good wonder woman cassie
sandsmark fans hate it when people talk
trash about her but
she's here basically with jonathan kent
now if you guys recall from the first
video that we did
uh jonathan kent uh had basically like
like where wonder woman was kind of
going awry jonathan ken had tried to
stop
wonder woman from being killed and that
led to him being impaled with the sword
alongside wonder woman right and what
that meant was when the sword was pulled
out of wonder woman through jonathan
kent her blood would have infected him
and that would have led to him being
infected with the anti-life virus and
that's exactly what happened and it's
kind of good that dc paid attention to
that right it's one of the things a lot
of you guys actually noticed too because
i was looking through the comments and
like one of the first things you guys
were saying was
as soon as that sword gets pulled out
jonathan's gonna be infected right it's
like the number one thing you guys were
saying i thought it was cool
right because i it didn't even occur to
me at the time when i was reading that
like it didn't even i didn't think about
that right so
it's awesome that you guys caught that
but yeah so once they grab him and once
they bring him in or at least with the
intention of bringing him in there's
there's a great big huge argument that
kind of breaks out between
black canary green lantern and with like
poison ivy over whether or not jonathan
should be allowed in here and the
response of poison ivy is no
we're not going to let jonathan in here
this place is literally a safe haven a
refuge
from those individuals who are infected
by the anti-life virus we're not gonna
let some guy in here just so we can
run into all this craziness and have to
basically flee this entire thing right
this place is held against the undead
for five years
we're not going to put that at risk and
so where you have uh you know
green lantern he's like well i mean if
he leaves i leave then the response of
poison ivy is then leave
we're not gonna let him in here and the
reality is they kind of have to abide by
that right if anything it's more of just
kind of like an
honor code a man doesn't walk into
another man's house and start telling
him what's what that's just
it doesn't work that way and and green
lantern cannot walk into this protected
citadel of poison ivy and then start
kind of calling the shots and pretending
to be the boss all that kind of stuff
because poison ivy will kick her out and
so she ends up grabbing jonathan kent
and uh and they end up bailing out and
so from there you pick up inside of uh
inside of the
the green in australia right out in the
outback and you've got you know kind of
a
a whole army of undead who are just
surrounding what's basically called this
blood mode right just
this gigantic mode and you've got this
great big huge building right you know
there's this huge
citadel of sorts now when they arrive
there you end up having shadow packages
kind of like okay so like we need the
power of zatanna we need you know these
individuals and what we need is to find
a way to basically fly
over the air flow over the the blood
mode and then once we get to the other
side then we can figure out what's going
on with the citadel and we can figure
out what's going on with the green
simple enough the problem with this as
detective chimp figures it out once he's
sort of looking in there the problem
with this
is that it's not blood and when they're
like what in the heck is it then
suddenly we find out
it's plastic man right this whole huge
moat is plastic man now here's the
important thing to understand guys
classic man is probably the most
powerful being on the
in the entirety of dc comics at least in
terms of earth-based superheroes right
he's not more powerful than the spectre
or anybody like that but in terms of the
earth-based superheroes he's more
powerful than almost anybody else he can
shape-shift he can become anybody right
so
unless you're somebody with telepathic
abilities like martian manhunter you
won't know who he is and i believe that
he can actually block martian
manhunter's telepathy right so if
martial manhunter can't read his mind if
he decided to face off against somebody
like superman he wouldn't have to punch
him he could just use his imaliability
and
just fill the lungs of superman with
himself and then suffocate him there's
almost no real
means to overcome classic man outside of
like freezing him
or swimming along those lines and that's
exactly what happens here
right plastic man tears through the
entirety of shadow patch ragman
dead zatanna dead blue devil dead like
every single
one of these guys is completely and
totally destroyed by plastic man
save for john constantine and detective
chimp and swamp thing who are just
falling endlessly
into the gaping maw of this massively
mutated
and twisted version of classic man
towards their grisly deaths so with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comments explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the raw
before if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and we'll
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
what's up
so
[Music]